THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC AND THE ECONOMY. I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YEAH MOBY
SERVICE COMMITTEE CHAIR TODAY.
JOINING ME AT THE DíAS ARE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHAO RAMOS
RIVAS QUIRK SILVA- AND I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH WHO'S REPLACING
SERVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
FOR THE DAY AND COME WITH A
VIRTUAL REPLACING. MEMBER
PHILLIP CHEN FOR TODAY. ALSO
JOINED BY TONY SIMON'S THE
CHIEF CONCERN. SINGLE ARE THE
CONSULTING WITH THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS. AND FROM THE COMMITTEE
OFFICE BENJAMIN MOORE HIDE THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE. IF YOU ARE HAVING
ANY TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH THE
CONFERENCE SIGNED BàN IS
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU HE CAN
BE REACHED AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
ZERO. TODAY'S AGENDA INCLUDES
ONLY ONE BILL SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. BY SENATOR REPORTS THIS
IS WITH US TODAY. AND YOUR
PATIENCE SIR FEW THINGS I NEED
TO RUN THROUGH QUICKLY IN TERMS
OF OVERVIEW OF POWER CONDUCTING
THIS HEARING TODAY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN THE BILL PRESENTATION.
ARE DUE TO THE CONTINUE STAY
HOME ORDER WERE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCHING PARTICIPATE
IN PERSON WE'RE REQUIRING THAT
MASS BE WARNED AS YOU CAN SEE
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEAT
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WHETHER YOUR HERE
THE ROOM. OR THE VIDEO COP IN
SIGHT. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. WE'RE HAVING A IN PERSON
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE HERRING IN
THE SPACE WE CAN ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMUM CONTINGENT OF STAFF.
AND LIMITED IN THE NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY TO BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND I'LL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WE
WOULD ASK THAT THE- ATTACHED
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL THIS THING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON. AT A TIME. FOR OUR
DIALING WITNESSES TODAY WE'LL
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. TO
REPEAT THAT IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND YOUR ACCESS CODE
WILL BE ONE THREE ONE. FOUR
THREE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. THIS NUMBER IS ALSO
LOCATED ON THE ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AGED. AGE E.
D. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G.
O. V. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. FOR CALLING IN PLEASE
AND TO DO IT BUT THE BIG THING
OF THE BILL PRESENTATION AND
THE OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO. THIS
INCLUDING ME. LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND MEETING YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
ADVISED IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE AND
WILL NEED TO YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALL TO SPEAK. EACH TIME
I WOULD ADVISE ON MATING
YOURSELF SO WE CAN AREA. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE ZERO. AND THEN WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP I SHALL
COMMITTEE IS ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE BEING MINDFUL
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK. COMMITTEE STAFF WHO'VE
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO ALLOW ALL
OF US TO HAVE A SAFE RETURN. TO
THE CAPITAL. TODAY AS A NOTE
ADDED ANOTHER WE HAVE ONE BILL
ON FILE AS P. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN CENTER BOARD JUST
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
REVIEWS TORY FAIRNESS ACT- WILL
WE RECEIVE NO ADDITIONAL
LETTERS OF SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FALLING LETTERS MISSION LINE I
BELIEVE OF A QUORUM WE PLEASE
CALL ALSO CAN SELL. YEAH YEAH
HERE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER HERE FOR
MORE LAST YEAR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CAP ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALIFIA
FAMILY MEMBER CHOI YEAH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOICE HERE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RALPH HERE THAT
WOULD HAVE A REMOTE HERE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MOVIE NOT. OKAY.
FOR UP HERE THE PHONE NUMBER
FOR PHILADELPHIA. IF YOU CARE
YOU HAVE WITH A QUORUM WE'RE
READY BEGIN OUR EGULAR BIZ
TODAY WERE HEARING US FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN- BEFORE SENATOR
BOARDS BEGINS AT PRESENTATION I
WOULD GIVE EVERYONE FORMAL
NOTICE THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW
OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO GET IN
THE QUEUE AND AGAIN THE CALL
THE NUMBER. IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR. THREE
SEVEN.THEIR BORDERS PLEASE
APPROACH. GOOD AFTERNOON.
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN I'D LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THEY WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH MY
OFFICE TO FINE TUNE THIS
LEGISLATION AND ADDRESS
CONCERNS AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PRESENTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
MODELED AFTER THE SMALL
BUSINESS REGULATORY ENFORCEMENT
ACT PASSED BY CONGRESS AND
SIGNED INTO LAW BY PRESIDENT
CLINTON IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ALLOWS
FOR REGULATORY RELIEF BY
REQUIRING STATE AGENCIES TO
ESTABLISH POLICIES TO PROVIDE
FOR THE REDUCTION OR WAIVER. OF
CIVIL PENALTIES FOR VIOLATIONS
OF REGULATORY OR STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS BY A SMALL
BUSINESS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
LESSEN REGULATORY STANDARDS ON
SMALL BUSINESSES OR REDUCE THE
RULEMAKING AUTHORITY OF THE
STATE AGENCIES. INSTEAD IT SIX
TO IMPLEMENT AN ADDITIONAL
REVIEW OF CIVIL PENALTIES
IMPOSED ON SMALL BUSINESS TO
PER TO PREVENT PENALTIES FOR
MINOR INFRACTIONS LEADING TO
FINANCIAL RUIN IN THE EVENTUAL
BANKRUPTCY OF A SMALL BUSINESS.
TO PREVENT BAD ACTORS FROM
BENEFITING FROM SUCH A POLICY
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE REQUIRED
TO MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA TO
QUALIFY FOR A PENALTY REDUCTION.
THE VIOLATION MUST NOT INVOLVE
WILLFUL OR CRIMINAL CONDUCT. IN
THE VIOLATION SHOULD NOT POSE A
SERIOUS HEALTH SAFETY OR
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT. SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ALSO
PROVIDES FACTORS FOR STATE
AGENCIES TO CONSIDER IF AND TO
WHAT EXTENT THE PENALTY SHOULD
BE REDUCED WHICH INCLUDE BUT
ARE NOT LIMITED TO THE DEGREE
TO WHICH SMALL BUSINESSES
COOPERATED DURING ANY
DESTINATION. THE DEGREE TO
WHICH THE SMALL BUSINESS ENGAGE
IN SUBSEQUENT ACTION TO CORRECT
THE VIOLATION. PRIOR HISTORY OF
pREGULATORY REQUIREMENTS THE
DEGREE TO WHICH A PENALTY WOULD
IMPEDE THE SMALL BUSINESS FROM
CONTINUING TO OPERATE. IN THE
DEGREE TO WHICH SMALL BUSINESS
ACTIONS WERE NEGLIGENT. WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THE STATE AGENCY
MAY ALSO APPLY CONDITIONS TO
THE REDUCTION OR WAIVER OF
PENALTIES. INCLUDING REQUIRING
THE SMALL BUSINESS TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION OR ATTEND TO
SPECIFY TRAINING. MANY HAVE
SEEN THAT RECENT EVENTS HAVE
PROVEN SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
INDISPENSABLE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS AN INTERVAL
SHARE OF CALIFORNIA'S THREE
TRILLION DOLLAR ECONOMY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
ARE A DRIVING FORCE IN JOB
CREATION AND TAX REVENUE. AS
NOTE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES MAKE UP 97%
OF ALL BUSINESSES IN THE STATE
EMPLOYEE ALMOST 35% OF THE
FORCE. AND THOSE WITH LESS THAN
TWENTY EMPLOYEES HAVE THE
STRONGEST NET JOB GROWTH. THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S BUSINESS
COUNCIL PUBLISHER ANALYSIS OF
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES. THERE
WERE ONE POINT THREE MILLION
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASE OF 27% FROM
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IN OF THESE
BUSINESSES 90% HAD. NO
EMPLOYEES OTHER THAN THE OWNER.
MINORITY WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA ALSO SAW THE
LARGEST PERCENTAGE OF GROWTH
WITH OVER 78% AMONG HISPANIC
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES 57%
AMONG AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES AND 44% AMONG
ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES. DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUSINESS AND WORKERS HAVE
STEPPED UP TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ESSENTIAL
SERVICES SUPPLIES AND FOOD NOW
MORE THAN EVER CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO TAKE ACTION TO PROVIDE
REGULATORY FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESSES THERE ARE A
VITAL PART OF OUR ECONOMY. SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL
FURTHER ASSIST CALIFORNIANS
DURING AN ALREADY TRYING ON
CERTAIN TIME. WE MUST MITIGATE
COSTLY ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS FOR
INADVERTENT MISTAKES IN ALLOW
THESE ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS OF
OUR COMMUNITY TO SUCCEED. THE
BILL WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
WITHOUT A SINGLE NO VOTE. AND
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AS BEING A FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER BORDERS. WILL YOU BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL ANALYSIS
UNDER COMMENTS SEVEN. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ACCEPTED ALL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OKAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL THAT THESE
MAMMOTHS. AND I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF WITNESSES BOTH
IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE MISTER DAVID BUTLER
WITH THE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK IS ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE MISTER BUTLER
IF YOU'RE THERE YOU YOU MAY
BEGIN YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DAVID
BUTLER AND I'M TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. ON BEHALF OF YOU CAN THE
UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK. WHICH IS COALITION OF
SEVEN LOCAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ORGANIZATIONS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IS OVER FOUR
THOUSAND- MEMBERS- ABOUT 80% OF
WHICH ARE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND OPERATORS. EACH FALL WE
SURVEY OUR MEMBERS ASKING WHAT
THEIR TOP CONCERNS ARE
RELATIVELY STATE GOVERNMENT AND
AFTER TAXES EXPECT EXCESSIVE
REGULATION IS CONSISTENTLY
THEIR GREATEST CONCERN. THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS THAT SMALL
BUSINESS OR A CENTRAL COMPONENT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC ENGINE.
HOWEVER EXCESSIVE REGULATION
ACT AS A BRAKE ON CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. ADVERSELY IMPACTING
SMALL BUSINESSES AND WHO DON'T
HAVE THE ORGANIZATIONAL
RESOURCES AVAILABLE
EXCEPTIONALLY NAVIGATE THE
STATE'S REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT.
THIS CAN IMPORTANTLY RESULT IN
SMALL BUSINESSES ON KNOWINGLY
BREAKING THE LAW LEADING AT
TIMES THIS IS SUBSTANTIAL CIVIL
PENALTIES. SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT
ROLE SMALL BUSINESSES PLAY IN
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY IN FIXED
POSITIONS STATE AGENCY THIS
PARTNERS IN THEIR SIX THAT. SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY ALSO BUILT UPON
THE PROGRESS MADE BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE KOBE IS ESTABLISHING SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATES WITHIN THE
BUREAUCRACY. SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
STEP BY STATE AGENCIES WITH
HANNIBAL OBJECTIVES THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN ANTICIPATE AND
THE LEGISLATURE CAN MONITOR. BY
REQUIRING STATE AGENCIES TO
ESTABLISH POLICIES FOR THE
REDUCTION OR WAIVER CIVIL
PENALTIES. AND PERMIT AGENCIES
DEBATE UPDATE THEIR POLICIES TO
BETTER REFLECT CURRENT ISSUES
AND CONDITIONS IMPACTING SMALL
BUSINESSES. SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN MAKE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
DRAFTING ONGOING CONCERNS OF
OUR CHAMBERS MEMBERS. AT THE
RISK OF REPEATING A WELL WORN
PHRASE NOW MORE THAN EVER IN
THE WAKE OF THE ECONOMIC
CONTRACTION BECAUSE QUITE A
BIT. SO SEATED SHUT DOWN SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER WHO CREATORS
NEED THE GOVERNMENT TO HELP
MOVE BARRIERS. TO FIX THAT. OUR
STATE TRULY OPENED.
CALIFORNIANS BUSINESS. AND OUR
ECONOMY WILL CRY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU FOR
PORT DISCREETLY ON THE ISSUE.
AND WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER BUTLER
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE WARRANT
SKATING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO ON THE LINE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. MR GETTING
PLEASE BEGIN YOUR COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAKING SURE
MEMBERS LORD GAIN POPULAR TO
THE CALIFORNIA FACTIONS ABOUT
HIS SITUATION I DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THINGS. IN THE
PROCESS OF A NEW MIDDLE MEMBERS
MY FOLLOW COM THE BILL. RIGHT
AND WITH THAT BEING SAID YOU
TAKE THAT THE PORT OF THAT
REPORT SEVEN AT THE BILL THAT
WILL HELP RETAIN AND BILL SMALL
MANY BACKING GOVERNMENT STATE.
THAT BECOME MORE CRITICAL IN
THE WAKE OF THE. OF THE
NINETEEN. HELLO HAS MORE THAN
TWENTY DOLLARS MANY BACK FARM
90% OF WHICH ARE. GUY FOR ME
FACTORED HIGH. OF I'LL BUT NICK
ME. THE DAY. AT THE COMMISSION
MEMBER OF OUR FACTORS BUDGET.
MANY OF THE STATE FOR MANY. OF
STEPPED UP WITH AND PARTNERS
THE STATE MICHAEL BUT NOT
RECOVER RESPONSE. THE CHALLENGE
SMALL BUT SMALL MANY FACTORS
THAT COULD BE BAKER THE LACK OF
PERSONNEL AND EXTENDED H.
ARCHITECTURE. DIGGIG TO KEEP
UP WITH THE INTRICACIES OF THE
DYNAMIC REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
STATE. ONCE MORE MANY FACTORS
WORKING ACTIVELY MITIGATE THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. MAKE A
MINOR AND OR UNINTENTIONAL
MISTAKE THAT IS NOT THERE AND
HELP THE STAKES THERE. THIS
BILL ENCOURAGE AND ASSIST THEM
CORRECT CORRECT. THANK RATHER
THAN AT THEM VERY STRICT WITH
THE AT THE RIGHT. ABOUT THE BAD
ACTORS IN GIVEN UP A- FOR SMALL
NAY. STATE OUR SPOT. THE BILL
THAT PROVIDE MACINNES COULD BE.
AND MINOR THEY- GET THE PART
LENGTH INTO SMALL. ADMITTED BY
THE FACT HI. ME WILL BE
GOVERNMENT. BACK ON THE JOB
HUNDRED ABOUT WOULD NOT. WE SEE
THAT THAT BETTER THE TEACHERS
ME BACK. AND CALIFORNIA CON.
FOR THESE REASONS RESPECT ASK.
THAT. WHAT SEVEN THANK YOU.%
THANK YOU FOR GETTING MR
MODERATOR IS THERE AN ELSE THE
COMP LINE THE WOULD WOULD LIKE
TO SEE AND SO OFTHE BILL. AND
ENJOY ON PHONE LAW IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS. TO AT THIS TIME TONE
INDICATE IN PLACING QUEUE THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU A
NUMBER THAT I WILL NOW TO BY
THAT NUMBER FORMER READY FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME I DO HAVE ONE IN
SUPPORT. I GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY AND WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN LINE IS OPEN. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE DATA ON THAT
FROM THE HALF OF THE CAL
PROFESSIONALS FUCHSIAN. ON'T
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AT ONCE AGAIN- LAID JIM ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO APPROACH AND
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEING. NO
ONE I BELIEVE WE CAN TURN TO-
WITNESSES OPPOSITION. PERCENT
WE HAVE KERR LANG OF NURSES
ASSOCIATION ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE. YES GET UP EARLY IN LIFE-
MR NEVERS WRESTLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED NURSES RE RESPECTFUL
THE POST F. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN AS PATIENT ADVOCATE THAT
THE TO ANY OF AN OFFER OF ILL.
PROTECTING AND SAFETY AND
ALLEVIATE HUMAN SUFFERING
NURSES HAVE A DUTY TO CHAMPION
WHAT IS FAR AT THE FED SO CAN
BE. OF COURSE. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN UNDER THIS BILL
BUSINESSES WILL BE A BASIC OF
THAT NET GOOD OR BACK CON OR
VIOLATIONS THAT PULLED THE HELL
FOR OR AND BY AND ARMY THREAT
SEE AN ANSWER THAT IS
INAPPROPRIATE ANY BUSINESS OFF
THE HOOK A LAWFULLY IMPOSED
PENALTIES THIS WITH DESCEND
DISCONTENT OF OUR CLIENTS WITH
REGULATION. QUOTABLE PLACE THE-
ORDER MORE UNDER SB FOURTEEN
SEVEN STATE AID ILL SPEND
THEIR TIME AND DIVERT THEIR
THEIR RESOURCE ON A UNNECESSARY.
CREDIT PROCESS AND- WELL AND
SAFE YOU WERE. FAMILIES AND IN
CALIFORNIA BUT REASONS ORDERS
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS MATCH
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LANG I
UNDERSTAND WE ALSO OF MONACO
YOSHIHARU FROM THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
ON THE LINE. IS BEGIN YOUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE ON THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUT THAT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND REACH YOU ARE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION AND
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE POLICY
OF THE SPELL IT JUST
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO THE
OBJECTIVE OUR CURRENT THE
FRAMEWORK WHICH IS RANKED
INCOME WITH LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. WE KNOW THAT
WORKERS LOSE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR IN THE STATE
ARE INJURED ON THE JOB AND
OFTEN IS THE RESULT OF ALL AND
THEN CON BUT SOMETIME IT CAN
RESULT THE I'M GOOD AT THE
GATED BUSY IF YOU MAY NOT BE
THE STEP THANK BE. THERE AND
LAW. SIGNIFICANT BUT WHAT DOES
THAT CIVIL PENALTY MAY HAVE A
PUNITIVE VERDICT ASK BUT THERE
PURPOSE IS TO SECURE A BEATING
THE STAFF YOU CAN READ IN TO US
IMPORTANT POLICY OBJECTIVE.
COULD BE USED TO OUR- THE
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
OBJECTIVES THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED BY THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN THE PENALTY PROVISIONS
WERE PASSED. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO REWARD BUSINESSES WHO
REMAIN UNSOPHISTICATED AND
UNEDUCATED ARE DEVELOPING LAWS
AND REGULATIONS AND IT PUTS
OTHER BUSINESSES YOU ARE DOING
THE RIGHT THING AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE UP TO DATE AND
COMPLIANCE WITH A LOT AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE. I
JUST. AT A RECENT REPORT BY THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S BUREAU A
FIELD FORCE MEANT WHICH STATED
THAT THE LARGEST SINGLE SOURCE
OF LABOR CODE VIOLATIONS THAT.
IS WHAT. AND IF I. WHAT YOU'RE
TO ISSUE AND I THE WAY
STATEMENT. AND THESE COULD BE
CAN VIOLATIONS THE NOT INVOLVE
WILLFUL MISCONDUCT THAT DIDN'T
AND CODES- AN IMMINENT THREAT
BUT THESE VIOLATIONS. HAVE
ENORMOUSCONSEQUENCES ON
WORKERS YOU MAY END UP GETTING
INJURED ON THE JOB. OR WHO
EVENTUALLY REALIZE THAT THEY'RE
NOT BEING PAID FOR ALL OR THE
WORK BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WHICH MEANT. AND
BELIEVE. SO ARE PROVIDE THE
DISCRETION AND AFFECTING. YOU
INTO A BUT WHAT. IF ALL FOR
EXAMPLE FOR A INSTEAD BY A- THE
FACT YOU SAYS IN AND FOR A
SECTION THE LABOR. SHE TAKE
COULD. WHETHER THE VIAL WAS AND
BURDEN. AND IN HIS OR HER THIS.
BY NOT PENAL AN EMPLOYER FOR
VIOLATE ONE THAT VIOLATION WAS
DUE TO A CLERICAL ERROR. MANY
KIND OF VISION THAT THE PENALTY
FOR BIO. IS UP TO YOU CERTAIN
AMOUNT. THERE IS QUITE A OF
DISCUSION ALREADY AND A LOT OF
FAILED THE EMPLOYER CAN ALWAYS
FILE AN APPEAL FOR A CALL TO
REVIEW HE STANDS AND HELP.
MEANT AND REDUCE OR WHATEVER I
DON'T SEE IF THEY ARE FOUND OUR-
THE. LEAVE THE OVER BROAD IT
UNNECESSARY AND AGAIN THE PA
POLICY OF TO COMPLY WITH OUR
LABOR AND SAFETY LAW WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY IN RIGHT NOW I OR IN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OF OPPOSED IT THE
TO KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS MISTER MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE AND
JOHN ON THE PHONE LINES AT THIS
TIME IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ANN
ARBOR WILL AGAIN TO GIVE YOU A
NUMBER AND I'LL ANNOUNCE YOU BY
THAT NUMBER. READY THE COMMENTS.
CAN. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION.
THAT'S WHAT ZERO AT THE. AND AT
THE TIME LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE
THREE THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION.
GOODNESS START WITH OUR FIRST
ONE- WILL FIRST GO TO NUMBER
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JACKIE OF WHAT THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA OFTEN RESPECTFUL
POSITION. THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MAP
ROD- ON BEHALF THE TEACHERS I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATE LETTER
THIS MORNING IN OPPOSITION BAT
ALIGN COMMENTS I'M WITH DNA AND
SEE LET THANK YOU. ONE
CERTAINLY THE GERMAN THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATE OR IS THERE ANYONE
HERE PRESENT IN TH ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SO. AND
SEEING NO ONE I BELIEVE NOW
IT'S TIME FOR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. CHAIR I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION FOR
APPROVAL. MOVED BY THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOICE SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA- I
HAD I HAD A COMMON PLEASE
ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT- UP
FIRST OF ALL. AS OR IN A
PANDEMIC IN NOTHING NORMAL BUT
WE NEED TO RESPOND TO WHAT IS
ACTUALLY OCCURRING AND FROM THE
NOTES HERE WE KNOW THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE INDEED BEEN AND
ACTED AND ONE. CAT THE- SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT DIFFICULT WE
MIND OUR OWN SMALL BUSINESSES
WOMEN VETERANS THESE BUSINESSES
ARE EVEN HIT HARDER. I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. AS WE KNOW THAT FOR
MANY OF US WHEN. THERE IS
SOMETHING BROKEN WE WANT TO FIX
IT LIKE WE GET IF THE TICKET-
ON OUR CARS. IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT I SUPPORT YOU JUST MISS
BEHAVIOR OR SAFE. WORK ARE SET
FORTH BUT SOME OF THE NOTES
RIGHT THERE'S A 70% OF
BUSINESSES ARE NOW DELAYING
PURCHASES SO AGAIN LOOKING. OUR
BENEFITS AND- PLACE EVER
BUSINESS CLOSED IS GONNA IMPACT
SOMEONE. 50% OF WORKERS AT
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH LESS THAN
ONE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES ARE AT
RISK OF LOSING THEIR JOBS RIGHT
NOW 4% OF THE VULNERABLE SMALL
BUSINESSES JOBS FALL WITH TWO
OCCUPATIONS FOOD SERVICE AND
CUSTOMER SERVICE I LIVE IN
FULLER TO JUST DAY ON TAP. UP
THE SLOPE. SAUCE TEAM IN SMALL
BUSINESSES. LIST NOT JUST IN
THE LAST WEEKS SO I DO SUPPORT
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN MOVE IT
FORWARD. FOR SURE I HAVE A
QUESTION THANK YOU I BELIEVE-
DOCTOR CHOI WAS NEXT FALL BUT
THEN AS PER OUR ABOUT FIVE AND
TRUMP'S. SENATOR WOULD YOUR
SIDE THANK YOU. THE BILL- WHICH
TRIES TO HELP A SMALL
BUSINESSES AS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER THIS IS ONE OF MY STRONG
INTERESTS AREA- AMONG AS MANY
AT THE- OF SHE IS SOMEONE A
WOMAN THAT BODY. WAS SO
CONCERNED WAS THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR MANY TIMES A
HARASSED BY INTENTIONAL. THE
GATORS ALONG WITH THE ATTORNEYS
SO MADE UP OF. FOR INDICATING A
D. A. IN COMPLIANCE. AND THE
SELLERS THE BEAT THE THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO WE'RE GOING. AND
WITHOUT GIVING ANY CHANCE TO
FIX IT. SO I WONDER WHETHER
THIS BILL. WILL COVER THAT KIND
OF A PRACTICES. THANK YOU THE
CHAIR IF I MAY. I THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLYMAN YOU YOU BRING UP A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT THAT THE
AND I SAY THIS AS AN ATTORNEY
AND A FORMER LAW PROFESSOR I'M
FAIRLY WELL ACQUAINTED WITH-
THE LEGAL PROFESSION IN HOW.
SOME FOLKS HAVE USED THE LAW TO
LARGELY AFFECT SOCIAL CHANGE
BUT UNFORTUNATELY. I AS CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS NOT ALL BUT CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS HAVE FOUND A SLIGHT
OR INADVERTENT MISTAKES AND
EXPLOITED THOSE TO THE POINT
WHERE A SMALL MOM AND POP FIRST
GENERATION BUSINESS GOES UNDER.
UNLESS THEY PAID THE ARE LISTED
AT RISK REQUESTED AMOUNT. I
THINK WHAT THIS DOES AND I WANT
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT. IT'S
CLEAR I THINK WE HAD A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS FROM FOLKS THAT HAD
CONCERNS- ELSER WITH ONE OF
THEM- IN THIS I'M DRAWING FROM
THE LETTER. IT IT IS CRITICAL
OF THIS BECAUSE- IT WOULD.
ALLOW FOLKS TO EVADE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF NEGLIGENT OR
RECKLESS CONDUCT. LET ME BE
FIRST TO SAY THAT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS NOW INCLUDES
NEGLIGENCE NEGLIGENCE AS A
CONSIDERATION. OR VIOLATIONS
OPPOSED TO HEALTH SAFETY OR
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT. SO TO THE
BILL ITSELF SAYS THAT IN ORDER
TO BE EVEN CONSIDERED FOR
DISCRETIONARY REVIEW OF THE
MATTER THAT IT COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN WILLFUL. ARE OR HAVE A
CRIMINAL MISCONDUCT. AND IT
SHOULD NOT HAVE POSED A SERIOUS
HEALTH SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL
THREAT. SHE SOME OF THE FOLKS.
ARE PROVIDE THESE LETTERS
WHETHER THEY'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BUT I THINK THERE
MAY HAVE BEEN A SITUATION HERE
WHERE MAYBE THERE WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. APPRECIATE THE
FULL BREADTH OF WHAT WAS
EXPLAINED TO GETTING TO YOUR TO
YOUR POINT. WE ARE NOT TAKING
WAIT A FORTY. FROM ANY STATE
AGENCY. I'LL BE VERY CLEAR NOT
TAKING AWAY AUTHORITY FROM ANY
STATE AGENCY IN FACT WE'RE
GIVING THEM. AUTHORITY IF THEY
CHOOSE NOT TO BOB EVALUATE ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF A GIVEN
MATTER. THAT'S THAT'S THEIR
PREROGATIVE AS IT IS THE
DEPARTMENT. WE'RE JUST ALLOWING
THEM TO CREATE A SYSTEM THAT IF
THEY WISH TO LOOK AT MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT THEY CAN'T
TALK TO THEM NOT UP TO YOU TO
ME IT'S NOT THIS PIECE
LEGISLATION SO YOUR BILL WOULD
NOT HAVE ANY ENFORCING POWER ON
THE SUGGESTION NOT AT ALL AND
SO YOUR QUESTION IS WHETHER NOT
THIS COULD HELP IN THE
SITUATION WHERE SMALL BUSINESS.
SAMPLE THE- UP IN. FOR THE
ELECTRICAL ON. A PORSCHE OF THE
RESTAURANT AND- OR WHETHER THE-
WHETHER THE HEIGHT OF THE DOOR
WAS AT A CERTAIN LEVEL. THIS IS
DESIGNED FOR THAT RELEVANT
DEPARTMENT TO EVALUATE WHETHER
THAT. FIRST GENERATION
IMMIGRANT MOM AND POP
RESTAURANT SHOULD GO OUT OF
BUSINESS BECAUSE- OF THE- OUR
CIRCUMSTANCE BUT BETTER YET IT
HELPS THEM. READ A SITUATION
WHERE THEY CAN REMEDY THE
PROBLEM WE WANT THEM TO STAY IN
BUSINESS WE DO GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT IT IF
THEY DON'T WELL THEN SHAME ON
THAT THEN THEY DESERVE POSITION
ALL THESE THAT ARE ALLOWED LAW.
THIS HELPS. HELP SERVICE PLEASE
HELP THIRD HELPS OUR
COMMUNITIES. OUR SHE'LL BE ABLE
WAS A LITTLE BIT STRONGER IN
THAT THAT DIRECTION BUT THEN
ANYWAY I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
BEGINNING AND- TO BE CONSIDERED.
THANK YOU ARE AT THE MOBILE-
UNDERSTANDING OF ON OUR LIFE GO
WILL FORWARD VIOLATION HIDE
OFFICES. ALL TABLE WHEN BECAUSE
SMALL PORCHES WHEN THE SOMEBODY
BUT THAT BUSINESS. CREATION OF
ADA COMPLIANCE AND THIS SECOND
QUESTION THAT'S A RELATED IS
THAT. ADA AS I STAND THAT'S
MORE OF A FEDERAL STATUTE SO
WHETHER. OUR FEDERAL AGENCY NOT
STATE AGENCY ORDER BE AFFECTED
BY THIS APPEAL SO THAT'LL BE
ANOTHER QUESTION. THAT LAST
PART SIR EIGHTY A OUR
REGULATIONS ARE MORE OF A
FEDERAL REGULATIONS WE HAVE MY
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE STATE
COUNTERPART REGULATIONS ON THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
WAS AT THE FAT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BUT I BELIEVE THAT IS
WHAT IS LONG AS WE LOOK UPON
THIS AS- THE STATE OF CAL HAS
IN. AMOUNT OF PART. AND
REGULATORY BODIES WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS SAYS WE'D LIKE YOU
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T HAVE THE MONEY FOR
THIS BUT MAYBE AT SOME POINT WE
WILL WANT YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
YOUR THE CONDITIONS AND IF WAY
THAT YOU CAN. ARM AS AWARE A
CIRCUMSTANCE CAN BE REVIEWED
FOR MITIGATING OUR PURPOSES
MAKING CERTAIN THAT IT DOES NOT
AFFECT THE HEALTH SAFETY OR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND IT WAS NOT
WILLFUL OVERTLY BUDGET THEN YOU
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO USE THAT
DISCRETION. ONE OF. EASIER FOR
THIS LABOR DEPARTMENT TO
IDENTIFY THAT THEY HAVE A PLAN
IN PLACE THAT WILL SATISFY- A
DISCRETIONARY MEAT. SO THEY
THEY MAY VERY WELL NOT HAVE TO
DO TOO MUCH OF REPORT- AT ALL
BUT THE BOARD CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE SO MANY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
BEAR ON SMALL BUSINESS I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE. ALL OF THEM
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. DEVISE
A PLAN THAT WOULD EVALUATE
WHETHER OR NOT DEPARTMENT HEADS
SHOULD BEAR ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE IMPOSITION
OF PENALTIES. I LIKE YOUR BILL
IT IF THERE'S ANY ROOM FOR
ADDITIONAL CO AUTHORS ARE CAN
YOU ACCEPT MISS CLOUT BELLAMY
THIS IS FIVE. WE RECEIVED
THIRTY NINE OUT OF FORTY WHAT'S
HAVING ONE WAS ABSENT IN THE
SENATE THAT'S VERY UNUSUAL.
BECAUSE I THINK EVERYONE OR
STAY THAT DO DURING IT HIGHLY
THE NEED. FOR US TO HAVE
BALANCED. APPROACH TO HELPING
OUR COMMUNITIES HELPING OUR
BUSINESSES YOU KNOW WHETHER YOU
KNOW THE FIRST GENERATION OR
WHETHER THEY'RE THEY'RE- PHONE
OR WHETHER THEY'RE A- OTHER
TYPES OF A ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
START UPS. AND WE NEED TO PUT
OUR ARMS AROUND- THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY BECAUSE WE ARE. GOING
TO BE HURTING IF WE DON'T TAKE
STRONG I. PROGRESSIVE STEPS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR- I
HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS- SO WHO
ESTABLISHES THAT THE ACTION WAS
NOT WILLFUL NEGLIGENT ARE
HARMFUL TO THE ENVIRONMENT WE
HAD OPPONENTS TO FIVE. IT COULD
BE IN THAT KIND OF DETERMINE
THE BEST A THAT'S A FANTASTIC
QUESTION THE BEAUTY OF THIS
PROPOSED LEGISLATION IS THAT IT
IS GIVING THE AUTHORITY TO THE
RELEVANT DEPARTMENT. AT THAT
DEPARTMENT WHETHER IT BE A
DEPARTMENT HEAD OR WHETHER BE A
TEAM- WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
ITSELF AS THEY PUT FORWARD
THEIR OWN AND- THAT WILL ALLOW
FOR A REVIEW. BY MATT IT'S
GONNA BE A TO THE- TO THE TRUCK.
HE THE APPROPRIATE TO SIT
MAKING OUR UP. FOR OUR POSITION.
AND IS THERE A CATEGORY OF
PENALTIES THAT CURRENTLY DOES
NOT HAVE DISCRETION THE UP
OPPONENTS PER OUT THAT A LOT
OF- PENALTIES HAVE DISCRETION
TO BE ZERO IF FOR EXAMPLE THAT
EXIT GET SOMEBODY WENT OUT- I
WANT TO REFER. THAT OVER YOU
KNOW ESPECIALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS COMP THAT NOT BEING THERE
ARE NOT HAVING PAID JOBS THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE NOT WE FELL NOT
GEN BUT I'VE WOULD HAVE EFFECT
ON SOME OF THE FILE TV RIGHT
NOW. I'M OR IS THAT YOU WERE
PUT LTTLE AT WITH NO CURRENT
AND LAW. DESIGN AND DEPARTMENTS
TO THEIR OWN OWN POLICY AND.
FOR EXAMPLE USE THE BOND I'M
GONNA CALL RECORD LABOR IF THE
LATE DIVISION REALIZES IT
STATUTORY WORDING GIVE SOME
DISCRETION WITHIN THAT RESOLVES
THAT IN THE INSTANCES OF IT
MEANT THAT MEET HE DOESN'T HAVE
STATUTORY REGULATORY AUTHORITY
TO USE ITS DISCRETION THE MAP
WHEN I IS WHEN I THINK IT WOULD
BE ACTIVATED THIRTY WHAT'S THAT.
RUN THROUGH. THE FORMULA HE
WILL SET SOME. SO I GUESS LAST
YEAR AROUND A BILL- ON AND-
THAT REALLY LOOKED AT
SUPPORTING SMALL BUSINESSES
I'VE HAD TWO SMALL BUSINESSES
SO I'M ONE OF THOSE MOM POP SO
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE
PRESSURES OF CALIFORNIA. LABOR
CODES- AS THEY APPLY SMALL
BUSINESSES. GUESS WHERE I
STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL IS. IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC. OUR
BUSINESSES NEED HELP NOW YOU
AND YOUR BILL USE OF TAXPAYER
MONEY NOW FOR SOMETHING DOWN
THE ROAD THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
NECESSARY WE DON'T KNOW THE
CATEGORY OF. OUR AGENCIES THEY
HAVE DISCRETION. AND I KIND OF
THINK AS AS AND SUPPORTING
SMALL BUSINESSES. YOU KNOW IN
MY MIND THE WORLD IS ON FIRE
AND WE NEED TO BE YOURSELF NOW.
AND IT CHALLENGING TO SUPPORT A
POLICY. THAT USES MY DIVERTS
MONEY FROM SMALL BUSINESSES NOW
TO THIS OTHER THING ON THE
ROAD. I CAN'T THINK WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING. REALLY
EDUCATING OUR SMALL THE SPECIAL
MICHAEL BUSINESSES I THINK THE
OF THE TWENTY N. UNDERS ARE THE
ONES I ALWAYS WORRY ABOUT. A
CITY. YEAH I KNOW WE'VE DONE
SEVERAL. I'M NOT WE DO I THINK
WOULD BE HELPFUL AT AND BETTER
OF TAX MONEY SO I GONNA PUT
STAY OFF TODAY BUT APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS IN AND ACTUALLY
THINK WE NEED TO DO MORE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. HE IF I MAY.
THE CHECK YOU BRING SME VERY
IMPORTANT POINTS- THE ORIGINAL
DRAFTING OF THIS WHEN I WENT
THROUGH THE SENATE I HAD AN
APPROPRIATION. AND IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE WITH WITH
LEADERSHIP AND BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE MOST
OBVIOUS. WE REALIZE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ON IN A FINANCIAL
POSITION RIGHT NOW. BUT I THINK
WHAT'S WAIT WHILE WE CAN
DISSIPATE THE RECOVERY IS WHAT
TAKE A GOOD AMOUNT OF TIME. SO
THIS BILL DOES THAT. DOES NOT
ACTUALLY HAVE AN APPROPRIATION
ATTACHED TO IT. IT IS DESIGNED
IN ITS IN ITS FORM NOW THERE IS
NO PREPARATION ATTACHED TO THIS
THIS IS THE FRAMEWORK. AND AS-
THINGS MOVE FORWARD- I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL I DO
DEEPER DIVES AND WE'RE
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES CAN
EXIST IN THE FUTURE- AND THEN.
CREATE THESE- CREATE THESE
DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT- SELF
REVIEWS AND SELF PROPOSALS- BUT
TO YOUR POINT. YEP WE'RE ON
FIRE RIGHT NOW I AGREE AND- WE
HAVE TO IN THE BEST
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
TOMORROW YESTERDAY. I THIS IS I
THINK ONE OF PART OF A LARGER.
OF POLITICAL DIRECT IN THAT WE
GO HEALTH. I NOT GOING TO OF
EVERY. WE SEE IT NOW BUT IT
WILL BE HELPFUL DOWN ROAD
THAT'S MY BELIEF. MR RAHMAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU- SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS SOME TIME THE
BILL TO CHART TENSION-
CERTAINLY SMALL BUSINESSES
NASCO THAT THE SENTIMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE SUCH AS FAR
SUPPORTING SMALL BUSINESS. WHO
ARE ASKED. A LOT DURING THE
NINETEEN PARA ONE SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULD HAVE TO PUT OF
PETITIONS- OPEN UP AND THEN BE
TOLD NO THEY CAN ONLY SERVE
OUTSIDE. SO THERE IS SOME SOME
NEED FOR THE SMALL BUSINESSES
AND- THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND NINETY SEVEN PERCENT. OF
THEM ARE TOO SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW.
IN THIS BILL- STARTS TO ADDRESS
THAT DOES NOT AND STUFF ALL IS
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
FACING BUT STARTS TO OPEN UP
THAT DIALOGUE THAT DISCUSSION.
MILLER TO WHAT'S HAPPENED
AROUND THIS DAY THIS SO SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED TO BE THE
BACKBONE OF. ME IN LOT ELECTION.
AND DURING THE CALL THE NIGHT
ERA. BE ABLE TO LOOK AT. SOME
PROTECTIONS FOR BUSINESS WHERE
AT IN THEM. ONE GEN REVENUE
WOULD HELP THE LOCAL JURIST.
RIGHT DURING THE BRING MONEY
INTO THE GENERAL FUND OR AT
THEM TO DO A LOT BUT THIS START
NOW OKAY. FOR SAYS. BUSINESS IS
THERE ARE THERE ARE ENGAGE
WILLFULLY IN A LAWFUL MANNER
NOT BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT
ENGAGE IT WILL FOR MANNER WITH
REGULATIONS THAT ARE THERE. SO
THIS BILL STARS TO THAT DISCUSS
FOR. THIS IS A BILL THAT I'LL
BE. TO THEIR WOULD JOIN YOU AS
A CO AUTHOR THIS BILL AND WOULD
URGE MICHAEL TO. THIS BILL AS
WE- IS OUR BEEN A MOTION. A AND
I BE SUPPORTING BILL. YOU. OF
COURSE SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. I THINK WE'RE
SEEING THE IMPORTANCE OF THAN
LIKE WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE
DUE TO. YOU KNOW THE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC IN THE
ASSOCIATED JOB LOSS WHICH WE
ALL HOPE IS. RELATIVELY TO
HURRY- BUT PEOPLE ARE REAL HER
NOT. ALSO LIKE TO JUST BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON THE POINT THAT HASN'T
BEEN REYES THIS DISCUSSED BEEN
VERY. ROBUST AND THOROUGH THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THAT- YOU
KNOW IF YOUR TACO BELL. RIGHT
WHEN YOU GOT THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES AND YOU
GOT. RESTAURANTS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY RIGHT IF THEY CAN. OF
ONE AGENCY. ARE THAT DETERMINES
WHAT HAS TO BE ON YOUR TIME
CARD OR WHAT. WHAT PAYSTUB WHAT
COLOR PAPER BEYOND WHATEVER IT
IS. YOU KNOW CHANGES THE
REGULATION RIGHT SAY THIS WELL
YOU. PUT A Y. Z. AS GOT A NINE
BY ELEVEN SHE TO PAY INSTEAD OF
ANA. FIVE BY EIGHT AND- IF YOU
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT RIGHT
YOU GOT LAWYERS LOOKING AT YOU
GOT REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
PEOPLE LOOKING AT YOU GOT A
WHOLE TEAM OF PEOPLE SITTING
SOMEWHERE. AT WELL AS CORPORATE
HAD. THEY'RE ARE A AND THE
SENATE REBODIED EVERYBODY'S.
THEY NEED BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE- IF YOU TACO TEMPLE. OKAY
AND THERE'S TWO TALK WITH TO MY
AND THEY THAT'S EX RESTAURANT
EVEN THOUGH EXCELLENT EXCELLENT
RESTAURANT. YOU KNOW THEIR MOM
AND POPS THE DATE THEY DON'T
EVEN KNOW SOMETIMES THE
REGULATIONS AND CHANGE THAT
THEY'RE THEY FALLEN OUT OF
COMPLIANCE BECAUSE THINGS OF.
HAVE CHANGE OUT FROM UNDER THEM
AND THERE'S NOT EVEN REALLY FOR
SOME OF THESE FOLKS A CLEAR
PLACED OUT OUT AND IN THE VIDAK.
IT'S NOT LIKE ALL GETTING
NOTICE AT THE- NON LAW AND ALL
THE SO THERE'S IT'S A REAL
TREAT FOR THE UNWARY AND WITH
THE- MULTITUDE. ELATION WE
HAVE. OUR STATE. MUCH OF WHICH
IS. A PERFECTLY REASONABLE AND
DIRECTED IT PERFECTLY LAUDABLE
GOALS. AS A AS A FAIRNESS ISSUE
JUST IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
KEEPING THE TACO TEMPLES OF THE
WORLD. I ABLE TO COMPETE WITH
THE TACO BELLS OF THE WORLD I
THINK OF. A FRAMEWORK LIKE
YOU'VE LAID OUT IN THIS BILL IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT THING TO
GIVE THE REGULATORS AT. YES TO
YOU THEIR HUMAN. INDISCRETION
AND ASSIST THE BEFORE THEY
ASSESS A FINE. OR SOMEBODY AND
ANCHORS OF LEGAL LIABILITY THAT
MAY EXCEED THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY. AND THE YOU KNOW WHEN THAT
HAPPENS AND I'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN
AS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER- I
OFTEN AS AN ATTORNEY- YOU KNOW
THAT'S REAL AND- REAL
UNINSURABLE LOSSES. THE RISK.
THINGS OF THAT SORT I HAPPY
SUPPORTED TODAY I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORKING GETTING IT TO
OUR HOUSE YOU. PLEASE ADD ME AS
A CO AUTHOR AND- AND LESS-
ANYBODY ELSE MORE COMMENTS I
THINK WE'RE READY WE HAD A
MOTION A SECOND SO THE GRATED.
ALL ROLE. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SET
TO THE SP FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM HI. YOUR CUNNINGHAM
HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH NOT VOTE. OF US
MEMBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER- CHAT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMOS HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US. SEVEN NEVER LOSE
REQUEST BY. THAT VOTERS SIX
ZERO SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN IS
OUT CONGRADULATIONS AND THAT
RETURNS THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
THAT'S ONE TO THANK EVERYBODY
HERE AND ALSO THINK- COMMITTEE
STAFF- GERMAN- EXCELLENT AND I
DIDN'T GIVE YOU A CLOSE I
APOLOGIZE. ROOKIE MOVE. I THINK
THAT I DON'T KNOW THE FROM.
RATED.